[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
renforcer le contrôle parlementaire une
priorité du Sénat
le Sénat a toujours été innovant dans le
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
avec par exemple la création de la
première commission d'enquête de la 5e
République en 1970 ou plus récemment le
renforcement du suivi des ordonnances
dans cette optique le Sénat a lancé une
mission de réflexion sur le contrôle
sénatorial au printemps 2021 à
l'initiative du président Gérard Larcher
à l'issue d'une large consultation
Pascal grunis rapporteur et
vice-président du Sénat a présenté on se
propositions pour améliorer l'efficacité
du contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
ces propositions s'articulent autour de
4 mots d'ordre clarifier coordonnées
densifier et communiquer comme le
souligne le président Larcher en se
mobilisant pour moderniser ses méthodes
de contrôle le Sénat exerce son rôle de
contre-pouvoir
nos missions de contrôle doivent être
encore plus réactives face à l'actualité
tout en maintenant leur qualité et
l'autonomie des groupes politiques
commission et délégation parmi les
principales mesures figures notamment le
développement des missions flash pour
réagir plus rapidement face à
l'actualité le Sénat souhaite par
ailleurs développer le recours au
prérogatives des commissions d'enquête
la semaine dernière la commission des
affaires sociales c'est ainsi vu
attribuée pour 6 mois de tels
prérogatives afin de mener une mission
de contrôle des EHPAD pour ne plus
dépendre des données du gouvernement le
Sénat entend également disposé d'un
accès élargi aux bases de données et
recruter des experts en traitement des
données afin de rendre les débats de
contrôle en séance publique plus
dynamique des formats de discussion plus
interactif et des débats d'actualité sur
les sujets qui ont fait l'événement les
jours précédents seront expérimentés
enfin le contrôle de l'application des
lois sera rénovée et un meilleur suivi
de la mise en œuvre des propositions du
Sénat sera organisée
pour découvrir l'ensemble du plan
d'action du Sénat nous invitons à
consulter la synthèse des propositions
[Musique]